[Music]
this dream wedding is a huge topic this
season for you what is something that
you wanted to make sure was included in
the wedding you'll see everybody happy
dancing that is everything included I
know one thing too a dress the dress
honestly was the Stars he didn't see it
before though right I didn't see the
dress but the dress designer is Albanian
and met her to him and it was the most
beautiful hope Couture wedding dress it
was designed by Kachina Bocce who she's
actually really good friends what was
your reaction when you saw Stacy
in this dress to be honest for me
amazing thing yeah well we know that
finances were a huge discussion that's
something we have to talk about
it's time that flooring gets a job had
your green card for a year and why
haven't you gotten a job yet what do you
say to fans who just wonder you know are
you taking advantage of Stacy I think
people need to wait a little bit
I'm going to see I'm going to open my
business soon yeah that I'm going to say
well Stacy told us something you're
great at
Furniture designing furniture
yeah could we see a Florian Furniture
line I mean it works it goes together in
the future
my dad have company before and I learned
from my dad
fool my family understand to work and
Furniture my sisters my mom my dad like
family business basically yeah do you
feel like you're waiting on the perfect
moment to start I like it to start big
no like little piece there little piece
there you know my phone yeah do you ever
because I know waiting to like to put
the puzzle together you know my point I
like to the big one I know like 1000 one
month and one days you know my phone you
gotta start somewhere though yeah I know
but like from the ground up that's how
it works but he's like us he's he thinks
big and I think
yeah well I taught you that go big or go
home but you're not gonna be perfect
when you start you know you got you just
have to start to become perfect like
already I know that business how goes I
know the work you know my point is I'm
not like learning right now and starting
a little bit a little bit already I know
that to work yeah well I can't wait to
see it I can't wait to see your designs
one day all right let me know to design
your home I mean this place is gorgeous
I'm sure you have nice taste well Florin
you've had a front row seat to Stacy and
Dynasty's relationship for a while now
what do you love the most about their
bonds those they like have big heart and
givers boats
we serve this for
his dad his dad is like
amazing father
he's both he's lucky to have that father
yes we are and Mom and Mom
hello Dad is like very Giver he's like
they get it from their dad yeah it does
it for my dad
plus just like life is really short this
loves his brother he loves you love
somebody you love
you don't care no more like you want to
give everything yeah you know my voice
like make people happy basically yeah
how do you feel because you're away from
your family as well right how has it
been for you
for me to be honest it's been very very
like
tough year
this is going to be hurts in my heart
for my life so my sister passed away
your sister yeah wow I'm sorry to hear
that
passing of a sister and I feel like
we're gonna get let's go to Albania as
soon as we can yeah yeah well I hope you
do
and pray for your healing thank you
Maureen
you made it oh Jesus oh okay Florian
you're living this life now with Stacy
and Darcy you're on television every
week is this something you've imagined
for yourself I grew up very simple
yeah
by like
I don't have this what they did what
these kids had this day I watch I grew
up like I'm
happy to be honest very happy you don't
need so much to be happy
yeah so that doesn't mean for me like
you'd be happy for me it's everything
it's no I mean like you've been TV
you can be in TV for better for good you
know
when it comes to Darcy's dating life
Lauren why do you think she's had
trouble finding true love I think you
get troubles he's like
is give to the people in a second
everything you know my point
you give it heart and everything for in
a second
and people say like some people taking
it in good ways some people take it bad
way most of the people taking bad words
you feed the bird fast you give
everything to Liberty Bird foolish live
a good little bit is something little
bit is coming at home yeah
okay
well your best friend Georgie yeah is
gonna make an appearance for this season
thank God my best friend's coming
thirsty X Georgie
he's good to have him big mother problem
is he really your best friend yes my
friends to be honest and like
Georgia likes
he's a very nice guy for me yeah for my
perspective yeah and like I don't know
what to say so much for Julie like it's
my friend isn't it why did you not tell
Darcy he was coming I don't want to tell
him that Mommy and JoJo like probably
not going to feel comfortable but you
know my point I want to have fun I'd
bring him to her family I know bring him
like
okay okay is there anything you want the
viewers to know about you that you may
feel like they have a bit wrong for me I
live my life for myself I live for
people I'm going to stay home and I'm
going to live nowhere basically so many
people think he's so funny yeah very
comedic you know he's actually a really
good guy and he's
he's just a big lover
[Music]